I'm a mark 2 1 action my name is Albert
Minh I'm executive producer and
showrunner of Yellowstone live my name
is Jeff Hogan I'm gonna be filming
fevers possibly some Cougars nobody's
really had the vision to take on
something this big National Geographic
is the first my passion for the wildlife
came before my passion for filmmaking
when I'm in the wilds I'm at home this
is how the wildlife really is in
Yellowstone in real time it's kinda like
the ultimate reality documentary the
other sock is one of the biggest
volcanoes in the world I wouldn't be
surprised if we're all surprised this is
real this is live anything can happen
and that's the magic and yellers done
in the dress cool that was great guys
[Music]